President Chavez presidents and prime
ministers ladies and gentlemen
the basic promise of democracy is
equality
it should not matter whether you are a
man or woman
it should not matter how you identify
yourself
it should not matter how you look what
family you come from or who you love
it shouldn't matter whether or not
you're part of the majority
in a democracy everyone must enjoy equal
rights and opportunities
but equality is not a given
it is an aspiration that is constantly
challenged including within our own
Democratic societies
some people continue to be discriminated
because of their color their faith their
gender
or because of who they love
the path towards full equality for all
citizens is long
including in Europe
but we are moving forward
for instance the European Union has
launched a new push for equality in the
workplace with equal pay for equal work
so that women earn the same as their
male colleagues
or with a child guarantee
so that all families can afford child
care
or with a fair minimum wage
so that all workers can enjoy a decent
living
we also set out a new initiative Against
Racism and anti-semitism
and strategies for the rights of persons
with disabilities
and lgbtiq equality
that is the unique strength of democracy
democracies deliver opportunities for
all
today
we see that this basic principle is
threatened
not only within societies but also
between states
Russia could not accept that the people
of Ukraine would choose their own path
Putin is trying to deny this nation's
right to exist
to deny that ukrainians exist as a
people
with their history their culture their
identity
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine is an outdated Imperial War
a war against the right of all countries
and all people to exist
to determine their own future
for many Ukraine may seem a foreign
country far away
but the values and wishes of the Brave
ukrainians couldn't be closer to us
the right to be themselves
the right to live freely and
independently from the grip of a
neighbor who feels mightier and Superior
billions of people on all continents
share the same desire
and this is why Europe will keep
standing by Ukraine
because they are also defending our
values and our democracy
thank you